yeah welcome to this video playing not
zombie walk from Sweden yeah let's play
the way see what then what happens yeah
they all played these three nowadays
yeah and everybody enter uncle is
playing the marshal young age three as
the move for one ng anti Marshall can
you also play this one let's just
experiment with this it seems that I hit
on some some theoretical line even is
playing a rather quickly okay this now
looks a bit like the Sun arc engelsk
variation just with a 3 plate some extra
protection to e form
interesting young let's
kionda certainly a.m. should be should
be fine for black is looking rather
active here in this position
hmm f2c 80 interesting yeah I was more
expecting him to play for f5 using the
rook on a fade but ok where this this I
should should do getting him into the
spin it's not so easy to get out of this
check
probably this bishops good on b6 yes now
I try to use the F aisle to h2 we am
probably because Knight g4 is a good
further attacking news how does he even
protect it now I guess it doesn't yes I
can just take f6 now hmm here not so
sure if it is it's a good idea hmm but
how do I not take now probably I need to
okay yeah this this night sir is badly
positioned probably needs to go to f3
yeah you for I need to cover
night queen 22 d 3 a 2 g-3 maybe Knight
to f3 yeah but it doesn't look like i
really have anything here it's more like
black is fine you know you know you know
black is in good shape him
yeah of course I've my extra bonus it's
not worth much the only thing that
asleep three the III porn is doing is
covering define their form this is
something at least with without the
Pawnee would have looked at four and so
on and this year doesn't have none
uh-huh interesting interesting
okay I wanted want to go to f3 anyway
now here at least an item now has some
ideas second only five at some point on
supporting here h4 h5 oh this is a very
ambitious
hmm yeah the question is should i should
can I take only five here or is this
completely completely ridiculous so
don't know i should do do it quickly if
I intend to do it yeah and now I'm
hoping for the pawns the only asses
check I've got a good good square on
edge to its it's relatively safe
hmm before five sixes the idea of course
or just taking maybe he can play I have
threatened a threat knowledge before I
forgot about that yeah Roxy one maybe
when I get Queen d2 will see one it's
not a big problem
I look f2 can just play rook f2 idiot
sick I'm warning ya of course no I'm
just dead lost yeah what is this hmm
yeah Queen d2 us really idiotic I mean
probably it's not good anyway but still
you can always fight with a couple of
pounds now probably this wasn't the
greatest idea ever to take them probably
I need to take first can always play
play something like that I'll try to get
the porn yeah it's a bit problematic I
probably need to do something LCM
improve the position first the problem
is yen now I need to take really or
retreat I mean you cannot allow them to
take on g4 you just this was wasn't and
this this is just the position where
only only black can be better this thing
was okay improving pieces and putting
the night down and then he played the
smooth which is really quite ambitious
there maybe this is ok I mean I probably
wouldn't have played it because black is
in a position where you can just slowly
improve
I'd letter glad to win at the end so
yeah took the capture is just bad
problem yeah I can also play B 3 this is
this is fear much stronger who came
takes yeah it takes there now I need to
take it of course yeah i saw this rook
see one but i thought Queen d2 what
would be okay I can take and play
something like this or queen deform now
but he's got this and this is probably
just bad it's 95 idea now the progress
is really in the middle game I played
all those moves relatively quickly but
here this this Knight to g4 this was
wasn't great because it commits to to
taking it that doesn't help i need to do
something like this first improving and
then see how i can make progress there
are ways Queenie to h4 h5 and so on he's
rather passive always tied to their six
porn I think black is is much rosier the
computer likes black he thinks blacks
better and this is just a just a joke
but get blacks not better maybe it's
equal or something but black can never
be better here because he doesn't have
any constructive idea a5 before ok but I
think I'm too quick on the Queen's on
the kingside h4 h5 and stuff this h4 h5
is not a window something but I can make
some progress IAM and actually force the
problem after this oops I'm committed to
this and exchanging those nights against
each other sighs just not so great and
two looks are better than the Queen in
this position
all right yeah an interesting game
nevertheless